- [DRock] There he is.
Right there.
(laughing)
- On this episode, I
sneak out of jury duty
to bring you the show.
(hip hop music)
♫ Gary Vee
♫ You ask questions
♫ And I answer them
♫ This is
♫ The #AskGaryVee Show ♫
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 114
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Today was a show that was
not supposed to happen.
As you guys know, yesterday I mentioned
that today would not happen.
But it's a little bit of a curveball.
This is a very special jury duty edition
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
I saw an opening, a big opening,
they gave us for lunch.
I e-mailed the gang.
(dinging sound)
And here we are.
And I guess that's it.
First, big love to the VaynerNation.
So many lurkers came out.
So many of you talking about
the awesome energy of episode 113.
I agree.
Instant classic, India, in my opinion.
And I guess we should get into it.
So India,
let's get into
(mumbling)
the show.
- Damn it.
- [Voiceover] Gerald
asks, "If your kids wanna
"join the family biz, will
you start them at the bottom?"
- Gerald, if the kids wanna go
into the family business,
which is really interesting to me.
I'm super curious what ends up happening
with Misha and Xander.
Honestly, at that point,
as I project 15 to 20 years out,
I feel the empire is gonna be
at such a level, that
it's gonna be (mumbling).
Crap, the family business in 20 years
may actually be the Jets.
Yes, 100% I will actually,
1000% make them start from the bottom.
I'm gonna throw a curveball.
And I know little Xander, little Misha,
you're watching this right now.
Probably in five to seven years from now
where you can comprehend this,
but I need ya to see this
and I need ya to know your dad
is not bullshitting you.
Not only will I make them start
from the bottom,
or let me rephrase,
I'll make them start from
the appropriate place
that their education or skillset
as a young entrepreneur
or executive created,
just like I would treat you or DRock,
or anybody else.
But here's the way more interesting part.
I won't let them ascend
to being number one,
at least while I'm alive,
unless they ascend to be number one.
I think the thing that I'm most proud of
both in Wine Library
and with VaynerMedia
is we have friends and family involved
in both businesses.
And the levels that people play in
are actually all over the place.
This is something you guys know.
You know so many of A.J.'s dear friends
are involved in the company.
And you know that there's
just different levels.
We're not gonna get into names.
But like, people are
playing at different levels.
And obviously, kids are different.
And I could be, conceivably,
completely full of shit because I'm not
completely quantifying the enormous
amount of love that I'm
going to gather in them
over the next years.
But I have a funny feeling
that my respect for
meritocracy and capitalism
is gonna force me into that game.
And number two,
I'm thrilled to write them a nice check,
more than 99% of people deserve,
for them to go do their own thing
if they don't like it.
If you don't like it Xander,
go do your thing.
Misha.
(siren blaring)
- [India] Right.
- [DRock] Let's move over this way.
- Oh, you're mixing it up, huh?
I like how DRock's mixing it up.
You better have kept the gray
as we kinda moved.
Alright.
- [India] Alright, from Ginson.
- Did we get my green on green on green?
Did we get my, give me the color now.
I went super Peppermint Patty
up on 114.
So you like this, right India?
- That's my favorite color.
- Nice, awesome.
Alright, DRock, let's go.
- [Voiceover] Ginson asks, "Do you work
"on your birthday?"
(spitting)
- Couple things, my man.
Number one, I hate my birthday.
My 40th birthday is coming
November 14th of this year.
That was a little bit of a specific drop,
mainly 'cause I want
the entire VaynerNation
to buy me a lotta gifts,
Jets jerseys of random rare players
are at the top of the things that I like,
medium.
I've worked on every birthday
of my entire life, all of them.
Literally, even some in my teenage years,
'cause they happened to fall weekends
when my dad was draggin'
my ass to the store.
But since I became a
full-time professional at 22,
I've worked every birthday.
I've given a talk.
I gave a speech,
the RE/MAX convention for
Thank You Economy came out
during my birthday.
Like, gave a speech on my birthday.
Yeah, absolutely, that was
a silly question.
100% all in.
You wanna do what you
love on your birthday.
I'm lucky enough to
be doing what I love.
- [Voiceover] Ben asks, "How do you handle
"people missing deadlines they set?"
- Ben, this is an
interesting kinda question.
Poorly, because usually I...
Let me break this down, actually.
The way I struggle,
the way I react to people
who set their own deadlines and miss them
are predicated into the A and B bucket
that I put them in,
meaning, either I put you into a bucket
where you're a hardcore executor,
you're extremely reliable,
you're on your shit,
you're T's and I's and everything,
and that's what I value in you
because that's what you're great at,
if you miss a deadline, I am pissed,
'cause that's what you do.
Now if you're in the magic category,
gray, stumbling all over yourself,
calling out sick randomly.
Weird, but you got magic
and you make stuff happen,
well I kind of think
you're gonna miss your,
I actually don't even believe
you in the first place
when you set a deadline.
And so then I'm okay with
another two or three days.
So I think it predicates completely
on where I have you bucketed.
And then are you actually
executing on that bucket.
So that's how I react to that question.
- [India] For Cameron...
- Let's move it around.
Oh, look at me now.
(laughing)
I like the Citi bikes stuff.
Alright.
- [DRock] You wanna get on the bike?
- I don't wanna get on the bike.
- [Voiceover] Cameron asks,
"What are your thoughts
"on 3D printing technology
and the potential
"to integrate with social media?"
- I'm a big fan of 3D printing.
I think if you play it out at scale,
3D printing is one of the most
disruptive things going on
that I think a lotta people talked about
and it's not the hot topic right now,
which makes me feel like in 2019, 2022,
it's gonna pop and everybody's
gonna be like, "What?"
It's kinda like the
Internet itself, right?
After the dot com bubble burst
in '01 on Wall Street,
people kind of didn't realize
the Internet was only growing
and would really be a factor.
Same thing with 3D printing.
It got a lotta pizzazz.
Now it's a kind of soft period.
Everyone's talkin' about the
Ubers and the Airbnb's.
I think it's gonna really rear its head
in five to seven years.
How it integrates into social
is not interesting.
I'm not trying to be disrespectful.
I don't think that's interesting.
I think what's interesting is
if you sell a physical good,
between five and 100 dollars,
I think you have real disruption coming up
in five, 10, 15, 20 years.
Like, nobody's buying a
screwdriver in 15 years.
You're making one.
And that's intense.
And then 3D printing gets into
a real intense place,
including people arguing about gun control
in a world where people can be
printing guns in their home.
Like, who gives a shit about
gun shows and permits.
I'm printing it in my basement.
So society will evolve.
We will always adjust.
You go show somebody
who lived 150 years ago
all the intensity we deal with,
they would have thought
that we woulda killed
ourselves off by now.
Humans have a funny way to adjust.
I'm in on team human.
But don't get it twisted.
3D printing is a massive disrupter.
And over the next two decades,
will rear it's head for all of us.
- [India] Last one from Clinton.
(mumbling)
- Come back.
It's a little warm.
I kinda like the shade.
[Voiceover] Clinton asks,
"Are you ever scared
"before you do something big?
"Anything at all?
"It doesn't even have
to be business related."
- Clinton, the only thing
thing that I'm scared of,
really, in a public setting,
or that might sound big.
This is what the #AskGaryVee
Show is for, right?
We gotta show the 360.
This is probably gonna be one of the more
vulnerable things that
I've said on the show.
I'm setting it up,
but you're all gonna be like, "What?"
I am actually scared of reading in public
because I'm come to learn in the last
three or four years,
I am atrocious reader.
I really struggle with it.
As a matter of fact,
one of the big shifts
in 2015 that I've made
is I'm making a lot more five
and seven minute meetings
with my staff because I
don't read fast enough
for the value of my time.
Even when I read to
Misha, believe it or not,
I'm like a quarter of an inch hesistant.
Like, if I had to create
the greatest story
off the top of my head,
right now, for Misha,
I feel cozy and calm.
Reading Goodnight Moon,
I'm like (humming).
I'm just a terrible reader.
Like in Passover, reading
the things on the table.
I don't like to read.
It's funny, when I started getting asked
to do TV shows,
one of the reasons I didn't want
to do a TV show was
I didn't want to read off the chiron.
And even when I did my wine web
radio show on Sirius for nine months,
my first commercial read
was a disaster,
probably the worst thing
I ever did publically.
Guy came in, Sam Benrubi, big ups.
Father of many of the
employees at VaynerMedia
came in, he's like, "Do
what Howard Stern does.
"He can't read either.
"Just read it and then do your thing."
The second read was insanity
'cause I read it, I knew
what the Stella Artois,
ironically a VaynerMedia client now,
what that ad wanted to get off.
And I did an incredible read.
So I'm very improv.
I know what I'm good at.
I'm stunningly not scared of most things.
I'm scared of snakes,
somewhat of heights.
I really am, ultimately, scared of dying.
And weirdly enough, the first thing
that came to mind was
I really don't wanna read in public.
Badly.
That is probably at the top of the list,
believe it or not.
And that's kind of intriguing to me.
It's a funny kinda thing.
That's it? That's it, huh?
That was a nice, concise show.
If you think about the feedback yesterday,
everyone's like, "That's a long one."
Fun show. I'm really
glad I'm continuing it.
Super excited.
I saw a bunch of you saw
what I put out on Instagram.
I'll go to the official term tomorrow,
but I'm gonna do a Kickstarter-like thing,
probably tomorrow or next day.
And so be ready for it
where I'm adding at least
100 to 200 questions
to the #AskGaryVee book
that's coming out
early next year
that have never been answered before.
And I'm gonna do some sorta thing
where people that are watching the show,
if they preorder, I don't
know if I'm gonna do
50 or 100 books.
They get an automatic entry
and will be in the book
and then get a special
call with you, India,
to make sure the,
- [India] Wow.
- [Gary] to make sure that
the question is on point.
Appreciate all the support.
Big ups to everybody on Facebook
who's tagging people in the comments.
That means the world to me
because you're tryin' to pass on the show.
Glad I ran out of the courtroom
to bring you episode 114
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
And I felt tight with the questions today.
Question of the day.
Have you ever done jury duty?
And if you have, tell me your story.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
Psst, podcast peeps.
I know you weren't expecting a show today.
114, it's about to come at you.
It's hot.
Yeah, it's hot.
India, give me the podcast
exclusive (laughing).
Keep that laugh, DRock, let's go.
(hip hop music)